ukrainian forces have retaken the entire
kiev region
but russia's retreat
comes at a high price
northwest of the capital the city of
bucha
bears witness to the brutality of war
at least 20 people in civilian clothes
left dead in the street
each seen a grim snapshot of the chaos
and violence of their final moments
ukrainians say at the hands of russian
forces
days earlier the mayor of bucha
announced the liberation of his town
march the 31st will go down in the
history of our community as the day of
liberation the liberation of our armed
forces of ukraine from russian occupiers
so today i state that this day is joyful
joyful and this is a great victory in
the kiev region and we will definitely
wait until there is a great victory all
over ukraine
the joys of victory soon dampened
by death
ukraine's general staff is warning
buchar residents russian forces mined
the city before they left
combat engineers worked to clear
suspected mined areas
bodies remain where they fell
until it's safe to retrieve them
bucha's mayor says entire families were
killed and nearly 300 people have been
buried in a mass grave
not far from bucha in the village of
dimitrovka west of kiev the remains of
russian soldiers killed in fierce
fighting there left in the street
in the north of the country the
occupiers continue to retreat slowly but
noticeably
in the east the situation remains
extremely difficult russian troops are
moving to donbass and towards kharkiv
they are preparing new strikes we are
preparing an ever more active defense
as ukrainians begin to occupy and clear
recaptured areas what happened in bucha
ukrainians fear could be the first of
many instances of communities shattered
by this war
zain basravi al-jazeera level